SPEAKER: In our last
episode, we started
looking at best
practices that you
can use to get the most
value out of Cloud Logging.
We covered how to
ingest and store logs,
how to centralize them, and
how to manage log access
and retention.
Today, we'll wrap up
this topic by looking
at how you can use advanced
log queries to find
the exact logs
you're looking for
and how to manage logging costs.
Welcome to "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
Let's start with using logs for
troubleshooting and debugging.
I'm going to show you how to
use advanced queries to quickly
find the logs
you're looking for,
and how to use error
reporting to automatically
identify, classify, and
track application crashes.
An advanced log query is
the Boolean expression
that specifies a
subset of all the log
entries in your project.
You can use them to choose
log entries from specific logs
or services,
specify time ranges,
match specific metadata
or user-defined fields,
and even sample logs.
Let's have a look.
From the Project Dashboard,
let's go to logging and select
Logs Explorer.
In previous
episodes, you've seen
how to use the log's field
explorer to, for example,
select air logs being emitted
by our front end service running
on a GKU cluster.
Notice that our
selections are actually
converted into a query.
We can modify the query directly
without using field selections.
For example, we can negate
one of our expressions
to look for all logs
that aren't errors.
If we want to only get the logs
for a particular time interval,
we can easily specify that
using the Time Stamp field.
We can even retrieve
just a sample of the logs
by using the Sample function.
If this is a query
we'll need later,
we can save it,
and then access it
whenever we need it in the
future from the Saved Queries
tab.
So you can use advanced queries
to quickly and easily get
the logs that you want.
Saving your queries allows you
to get back to a set of logs
you need to review
on a regular basis.
Advanced log queries
are a great way
to quickly find the exact
logs you're looking for.
But what if this
was even easier?
You may remember that we
covered error reporting back
in episode 9.
If you haven't seen
it, no worries.
We'll link to it in the
episode notes below.
Just remember that it's an easy
way to track, analyze, and get
alerted on errors
in your application.
Advanced log queries
and error reporting
are really useful if
you're trying to understand
the behavior of your services.
Being able to quickly find
the logs you're looking for
and easily track
application crashes
should definitely help you
keep your services healthy.
Finally, let's get into
managing logging costs
which is a key part of
optimizing your Cloud spend.
I want to show you how to
view your logging usage,
how to track your
logging costs over time,
and how to control the logs
that you ingest and store.
First, let's have a look at how
to use information in the Cloud
Console to understand how much
of your bill is due to logging
and how much logging is
being ingested and stored
in your project.
From the Billing home
page, let's go to Reports.
Here, we can select our project
and the Cloud Logging service.
This shows us the
logging charges
we've incurred for
the current month
or for another time interval.
If we want to understand where
these costs are coming from,
we can go to logging log
storage and look at the usage
details for our default bucket.
This takes us to
Metrics Explorer
and shows us the
volume of logs ingested
by the various resources
in our project.
So that's how you can
use the billing report
to stay on top of your logging
costs and the utilization
metrics to track where the
logs are actually coming from.
Understanding your
logging costs is
key to being able
to manage them.
But actually
controlling those costs,
is primarily accomplished
by reducing the amount
of logs you ingest and store.
We covered log retention
in our last episode.
Remember that you
are not charged
for storing logs for the
default retention period.
As such, you can reduce
your log storage costs
by carefully
considering whether you
need to retain logs in
Cloud Logging for longer
than a default retention.
If you do need those
logs or other use cases,
consider exporting
them to Google Cloud
Storage for archival or
BigQuery for analytics.
Your primary mechanism
to reduce ingestion costs
are log exclusions.
Exclusions are configured
when you set up log sinks.
If you're looking to reduce the
volume of logs being ingested,
you can modify the default sink
to add an exclusion filter.
Remember that
excluded log entries
won't be available in the Logs
Explorer or Cloud Debugger.
Log entries that aren't
routed to at least one
log bucket are also excluded
from error reporting.
But with user-defined,
logs-based metrics,
our computers can log entries
in both included and excluded
logs.
Of course, the other way to
reduce log ingestion costs
is to produce less logs
from your applications.
For example, you can carefully
adjust the log levels
to control log volume.
This is especially useful
for serverless services,
where there's no way
to view excluded logs.
Consider both managing log
volume in your application
and using exclusions to balance
observability and costs.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered best practices for
querying logs in Cloud Logging
and managing your logging costs.
I hope these
recommendations help
you keep your service
reliable and your users happy.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]